We will now define the notion
of a random variable.
Very loosely speaking, a random
variable is a numerical
quantity that takes
random values.
But what does this mean?
We want to be a little more
precise and I'm going to
introduce the idea through
an example.
Suppose that our sample space
is a set of students labeled
according to their names.
Or for simplicity, let's just
label them as a, b, c, and d.
Our probabilistic experiment is
to pick a student at random
according to some probability
law and then record their
weight in kilograms.
So for example, suppose that the
outcome of the experiment
was this particular student,
and the weight of
that student is 62.
Or it could be that the outcome
of the experiment is
this particular student, and
that particular student has a
weight of 75 kilograms.
The weight of a particular
student is a number, little w.
But let us think of the abstract
concept of weight,
something that we will denote
by capital W. Weight is an
object whose value is determined
once you tell me
the outcome of the experiment,
once you tell me which student
was picked.
In this sense, weight is really
a function of the
outcome of the experiment.
So think of weight as an
abstract box that takes as
input a student and produces a
number, little w, which is the
weight of that particular
student.
Or more concretely, think of
weight with a capital W as a
procedure that takes a student,
puts him or her on a
scale, and reports the result.
In this sense, weight is an
object of the same kind as the
square root function that's
sitting inside your computer.
The square root function
is a function.
It's a subroutine, perhaps it is
a piece of code, that takes
as input a number, let's say
the number 9, and produces
another number.
In this case, it would be the
number 3, which is the
square root of 9.
Notice here the distinction that
we will keep emphasizing
over and over.
Square root of 9 is a number.
It is the number 3.
The box square root
is a function.
Now, let us go back to our
probabilistic experiment.
Note that a probabilistic
experiment such as the one in
our example can have several
associated random variables.
For example, we could have
another random variable
denoted by capital H, which
is the height of a student
recorded in meters.
So if the outcome of the
experiment, for example, was
student a, then this random
variable would take a value
which is the height of that
student, let's say it was 1.7.
Or if the outcome of the
experiment was student c, then
we would record the height
of that student.
And let's say it turns
out to be 1.8.
Once again, height with a
capital H is an abstract
object, a function whose value
is determined once you tell me
the outcome of the experiment.
Now, given some random
variables, we can create new
random variables as
functions of the
original random variables.
For example, consider the
quantity defined as weight
divided by height squared.
This quantity is the so-called
body mass index, and it is
also a function on
the sample space.
Why is it a function on
the sample space?
Well, because once an outcome
of the experiment is
determined, suppose that the
outcome of the experiment was
the blue student, then these two
numbers, 62 and 1.7, are
also determined.
And using those numbers, we can
carry out this calculation
and find the body mass index
of that particular student,
which in this case
would be 21.5.
Or if it happened that this
student was selected, then the
body mass index would turn out
to be some other number.
In this case, it would be 23.
So again, we see that the body
mass index can be viewed as an
abstract concept defined
by this formula.
But once an outcome is
determined, then the body mass
index is also determined.
And so the body mass index is
really a function of which
particular outcome
was selected.
Let us now abstract from the
previous discussion.
We have seen that random
variables are abstract objects
that associate a specific value,
a particular number, to
any particular outcome of a
probabilistic experiment.
So in that sense, random
variables are functions from
the sample space to
the real numbers.
They are numerical functions,
but as numerical functions
they can either take discrete
values, for example the
integers, or they can take
continuous values, let's say
on the real line.
For example, if your random
variable is the number of
heads in 10 consecutive coin
tosses, this is a discrete
random variable that
takes values in the
set from 0 to 10.
If your random variable is a
measurement of the time at
which something happened, and
if your timer has infinite
accuracy, then the timer reports
a real number and we
would have a continuous
random variable.
In this lecture sequence and in
the next few ones, we will
concentrate on discrete random
variables because they are
easier to handle.
And then later on, we will
move to a discussion of
continuous random variables.
Throughout, we want to keep
noting this very important
distinction that I already
brought in the discussion for
a particular example, but it
needs to be emphasized and
re-emphasized.
That we make a distinction
between random variables,
which are abstract objects.
They are functions on the sample
space and they are
denoted by uppercase letters.
In contrast, we will use lower
case letters to indicate
numerical values of the
random variables.
So little x is always a real
number, as opposed to the
random variable, which
is a function.
One point that we made earlier
is that for the same
probabilistic experiment we
can have several random
variables associated with
that experiment.
And we can also combine
random variables to
form new random variables.
In general, a function of random
variables has numerical
values that are determined by
the numerical values of the
original random variables.
And so, ultimately, they are
determined by the outcome of
the experiment.
So a function of random
variables has a numerical
value which is completely
determined by the outcome of
the experiment.
And so a function of
random variables is
also a random variable.
As an example, we could think of
two random variables, X and
Y, associated with the same
probabilistic experiment.
And then define a random
variable, let's say X plus Y.
What does that mean?
X plus Y is a random variable
that takes the value little x
plus little y when the random
variable capital X takes the
value little x and capital Y
takes the value little y.
So X and Y are random
variables.
X plus Y is another
random variable.
X and Y will take numerical
values once the outcome of the
experiment has been obtained.
And if the numerical values that
they take are little x
and little y, then the random
variable X plus Y will take
the numerical value little
x plus little y.
So we can now move on and start
doing some interesting
things about random variables.
Characterize them, describe
them, give some examples, and
introduce some new concepts
associated with them.